we now live in a world where
transparency has one speak the truth do
the right thing
kindness is cool truth is cool don't act
like you've made it talked about the
journey of trying to make it for me one
of the most interesting things that I
watch every day in this space is people
think that fake it till you make it is
still real there are so many people
posing it because they feel like they
have to inflate their backstory or what
they're capable of or the advice that
they're giving to break out yet that is
the exact same reason that they won't
break out I think too many people want
to fake it too they make it or project
someone they're not
which is why 99% of people are losing
it's just so crazy
all this fodder in the system that isn't
true all the faking it to you make it as
a fashion brand that's a greed or at
what every single [ __ ] 23 year-old
male in the world is doing which is
fronting on Instagram because boys want
girls and where I see kids getting
caught all day is their their fronting
they're making pretend they're posturing
this they're faking it to you make it
the problem with faking it too you make
it in today's world because you're
exposed I'll tell you what fake it to
make it is a kid rents a tuxedo rents
goes to his uncle's best friend's house
rents a Lamborghini drives it to that
house pays some Instagram models to come
and be in a bikinis and then say this is
my life and you can do this too if you
pay me $6,000 to teach you how fronting
posturing or my favorite that all of you
bought into fake it until you make it
look the [ __ ] part let me tell you
for all the homies that live life
looking the part for all you [ __ ] faces
wearing fake watches
and a suit that you can't afford because
somebody [ __ ] told you that you have
to look the part to win let me tell you
who you're fooling with your look the
part other [ __ ] losers
I think fake it to your make it
internally you know trick yourself that
you've got it that's good I like the
delusional thing yes yes yes
blind faith blind faith but when you
start putting that out to the world
now you're fronting now you're
bullshitting and you're losing equity
with the people that you want it again I
always tell people you're tricking
losers like like you're losing too much
when you fake it to you make it with the
a players of the universe like nobody's
tricking me like I know you bought your
fans your engagement blows the quickest
way for me to know somebody goes in the
L column for life is when they're faking
it until they make it you know this
whole fake it to you make it brings no
value to anybody you need to tell me
what you're gonna do which is very scary
because you actually have to execute on
you know listen I I always used to say
this it's like doing push-ups you and I
if we want muscles you have to do the
push-ups you can't read about the doing
the push-ups
you can't outsource doing the push-ups
and so and so there's a reason that
people who are authentic and actually
doing or winning because everybody else
is trying to figure out the shortcut
definitely don't overthink it right if
you're as good of a dude as you think
you are it all works out oh I'm
authentic me too man I got shortcomings
like like you know that's all it comes
down to as long as your shortcomings
aren't like real [ __ ] right like that's
that's why nobody wants to build their
brand cuz they're harassing people
because they're stealing money because
they're doing dumb [ __ ] that's why this
is working for me I'm growing because
the truth is winning more and more we
now live in a world where transparency
has one speak the truth do the right
thing
kindness is
truth is cool don't act like you've made
it talk about the journey of trying to
make it
[Music]